[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
صراخه
واحد فقط من بين العديد من البكاء في هذا المستشفى في
ولاية براديش المطلقة
يا طفلي يقول يا إلهي طفلي
داخل المدخل يقاتل ابنه ديباك من
أجل حياته وهو
يلهث من أجل الهواء يتشنج جسده
هناك  لا يوجد أطباء يعتنون به ،
فإن حفنة من الطاقم الطبي العامل في
هذا
الجناح ممتلئة إلى نقطة الانهيار
هذه المستشفى غارقة تمامًا
يقول الأطباء
أن لديهم حوالي 55 سريرًا
وهم يعالجون حاليًا أكثر من 100
مريض ويمكنك رؤية
الناس  يرقدون على
الأرض بشكل
يائس على أمل الحصول على بعض الرعاية الطبية
تقول كافيتا البالغة من العمر 32 عامًا إنها كانت هنا
منذ أربعة أيام
تتسول للحصول على الأكسجين الذي لم يأتِ
، وأخبرتنا أنه لا يوجد أحد يعتني بي
في الغرفة المجاورة أكثر من 20 مريضًا
معبأة بإحكام هذا ما تم
تمريره الآن لوحدة العناية المركزة
أخذ أفراد الأسرة دور
مقدمي الرعاية الأولية
حيث لا يتوفر الطاقم الطبي ببساطة
[موسيقى]
شارك هذا الرجل  لا أحد يغير
فراش زوجته
المتسخ فجأة هناك
ضجة ، هل من فضلك اتصل
بالطبيب
هذا الرجل تصرخ والدته ، راج بالا ، البالغة من العمر 55 عامًا ،
يبدو أنها تنزلق بعيدًا ،
ويعمل أبناؤها بشراسة لإحيائها
، يأتي الطبيب ويخبرهم أن يفعلوا ذلك  توقف عن
الازدحام
لكن العائلة لا تطاق ،
لقد مكثنا هنا لمدة ستة أيام ، واليوم فقط
لدينا جهاز التنفس الصناعي
لوالدتي ، يخبرنا
أنها قصة نسمعها مرة أخرى ، ومرة
ى يقترب منا رجل وهو يتوسل إل
زوجته لا تستطيع الحصول على سر
ر  لا أحد يستمع إلي ، لقد جربت
كل ما يقوله ،
الرجاء مساعدتي وإلا ستموت أنا لست
طبيبة ، أنا آسف للغاية لا أستطيع مساعدتك ،
أخبرنا رجل آخر أن زوجته
تكافح من أجل التنفس في الخارج
لقد فازوا '  لندعها تدخل نكتشف
مدير المستشفى ونطلب منه
ما يحدث ،
نعم هذا الرجل يقول إن زوجته تحتضر في
الخارج وتحتاج إلى
الأكسجين ، ويصر على أن الأكسجين ليس هو المشكلة
ولكنه يقول إنهم يفتقرون بشدة إلى
الموظفين
الذين يعملون هنا يخاطرون  تصبح
المرضى أنفسهم
يقولون لنا هؤلاء الرجال إنهم ينقلون عشرات
الجثث
يوميًا ، هل سبق لك أن رأيت شيئًا كهذا من
قبل ، ألست قلقًا من
أننا يجب أن نرتدي ppe المناسب كما يقولون
ولكن حتى الأطباء ليس لديهم ذلك ، فكيف
يمكننا سماع صرخات  قادمة من وحدة العناية المركزة
[تصفيق]
راجبالا قامت بتثبيتها مرة أخرى
ابنها يضخ
بقوة صدرها ، يأتي الطبيب في
هذا الوقت ، ولا جدوى من محاولة
إنعاشها.
النظام على وشك
الانهيار وحكومة متهمة بسوء إدارة
هذه الأزمة
[موسيقى] على
بعد بضع مئات من الياردات في
نفس مجمع المستشفى ،
إنها صورة
مختلفة تمامًا عن صفوف الأشخاص المنتظرين بصبر
حتى يتم تطعيمهم
بعد إعلان رئيس الوزراء
أن أي شخص قد انتهى.
يمكن تلقيح 18
شخصًا من بين 600 شخص يحصلون على لقاحهم
، ويقف مدير المستشفى
والصحفيون المحليون بفارغ الصبر
لالتقاط
اللحظة  كنت في المستشفى هناك ،
نعم
، كان من الصادم أن أرى أنه كان
صادمًا
لأن الظروف سيئة للغاية
هنا ،
لماذا تعتقد أن الهند تعرضت لضربات شديدة ،
يقاطعها مدير المستشفى
ويحذره من أننا نطرح
الكثير من الأسئلة  سيدي ، لست بحاجة إلى
تدريبه على ما تقوله
الآن ، فالشرط أفضل ، هل تقبل
أن الحكومة
قد خذلت شعبها في التعامل مع
هذه الأزمة
لأنني كنت أتحدث مع الكثير من
الناس وعلي أن أخبركم أيها الناس
يشعر الناس الغاضبون بأن هذا لا يجب
أن يكون
قبيحًا للغاية ، فالوضع ليس سيئًا فقط
هنا ،
فنحن نحاول إيجاد حلول يقول
إننا نزيد عدد
الأسرة ونعمل بلا كلل على
مدار الساعة
ولكننا نعود مرة أخرى  الجناح المغلق
لم يتم الشعور بتأثير تلك الجهود حتى الآن ،
وقد ترك جسد راجبالا لمدة ساعة تقريبًا
قبل أن يتم نقله أخيرًا
، وقد يعد قادة الهند بأن
كل شيء يتم القيام به لإنهاء هذه
الأزمة
ولكن في الوقت الحالي لا يوجد فريق  حزب التحرير في
نهاية نفق
كلاريسا جناح cnn ميروت
الهند